what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 27th of october the
joint is brought to you by me undies
get ready for turkey day with me undies
you already know they're the softest
[__] underwear in the world but these
puppies can stretch if you got your me
undies on thanksgiving
you could have seconds and thirds you
could eat a whole goddamn table that's
why i love
me undies i've been working with me
undies for eight years now
i got a whole draw full of them and i
wouldn't wear any other underwear
they're soft they're comfortable they
fit just right they don't interfere with
my [__] jeans and they don't go up
your ass half the time they are
tremendous this thanksgiving give your
gratitude some attitude you might not
get along with your creepy family but if
you give your cranky old [__] aunt
some panties she might write you into
the world take a chance columbus did
[__] me undies is the perfect
partner to get you through the holidays
thanksgiving christmas whatever it is
throw on their one seat it'll hug your
butt with softness perfect for watching
the game or just taking a little after
dinner nap on thanksgiving before dallas
comes on the best part is me undies is
for everybody available in sizes from
extra small
to big [__] like me with 4x i'm
not a 4x i'm like a 2x me undies has a
little something for everybody at the
table me on these has a great offer for
the joint family for any first time
purchases get 15 off and free shipping
free shipping and 15 off me on these
also has a promise if you're not
satisfied with any product for any
reason you can return your order for
full refund within 45 days
to get 15 off your first order free
shipping and 100 satisfaction guaranteed
go to meundies.com
joey's that's meundies.com
joey
j-o-e-y listen i love me undies i got a
pair on right now they're the reefer
underwear they're [__] tremendous
meundies dot com
slash joey the joint is also brought to
you by from the heart of [__] new
jersey
draftkings this saturday night live from
[__] abu dhabi it's ufc
blankowicz against glover texera listen
draftking sportsbook is the official
sports betting partner the ufc they got
a knockout offer for the title fight you
ready if you're new to draftkings i got
a deal for you and if you knew why you
knew how come you're not here already
what the [__] is wrong with you this is
the weekend to get on board i'm gonna
tell you why you got world series
you got ufc you got pro football you got
college basketball you got pro
basketball college football but you got
a tremendous ufc card this week with ufc
267 and next week november 6 it's live
from the garden [__] tremendous
five bucks on either fighter if your guy
wins you get 200 miles and free bets
will the champ hang on to his belt or
will the veteran from brazil snatch it
from him who knows either way you could
just bet five dollars and you can win
200 if the fighter wins listen to me
draftkings is great and i gotta tell you
something else they got a social network
on draftkings so once you go over the
draftkings i'll be putting pics on there
you could see what i'm betting i could
see where your bet will be friends on
draftkings and that'll get the party
started for [__] real draftkings is
safe secure and reliable best of all you
can withdraw your cash whenever the [__]
you want they got a tremendous casino
if i got five ten minutes i get the
casino and i put a dollar and you play
blackjack you play five hands i don't
know what i'm doing but i'm [__]
learning
you might as well have a good time
[__] so do me a favor download the
draftking sportsbook app right [__]
now use promo code joey j-o-e-y
then you throw five dollars on ufc 267
main event and win 200 and free bets if
your fighter wins it's that easy that's
code joey j-o-e-y
this saturday at draftkings and next
saturday there's a tremendous ufc card
and the ufc and draftkings will be there
for you remember must be 21 older new
jersey indiana pennsylvania colorado
tennessee and i also want to thank i
want to welcome connecticut if you're
from connecticut you got draftkings
coming at you new customers only you
gotta deposit five dollars that's it a
minimum wager is required of one
dollar five dollar deposit one dollar to
pick up 200 and free bets
the bad news is you only get one per
customer restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
slash sportsbook for details now if you
got a gaming problem call 1-800 gamble i
don't want no [__] people here
calling me up going joey you [__] me
i'm down ten thousand no that can't
happen on draftkings they're safe
reliable and secure you can't bet over
your head
and it's [__] fun you got the social
network you got football basketball ufc
nba and
that
download the draftking sportsbook app
better dollar on a fighter
bet five hours for the main event and if
it wins it wins 200 and free bets all
right
call 1-800 gambler if you got a problem
if not let's get this party started
download the draftking sportsbook app
and let's win some [__] money
the joint is also brought to you by
come on guys c
b d lion
i'll tell you part of my therapy has
been the cbd lion i put the 1 500
milligram tinction under my tongue
holy [__] it's like i go to acupuncture
every day i feel [__] great
listen to me i don't know if cbd could
help you
but go look check read
cbd cbn cby
cbn you [__] sleep like a baby
cbd it calms you down
it helps with pain relief
cbd line makes it for easier for you to
get cbd whether it's the vapor pen
the reefer the kinesiology tape the back
balls the extra strength cream
the gummy bears which are [__]
fantastic
listen i can't tell you all the great
things about cbd lion they've carried me
through the last two years and also
helped me through a surgery and host
also helped me through a little mental
[__] burp i had there
cbd lion is the best cbd available in
the market you're asking questions to
some [__] kid who never had a [__]
problem cbd line is tremendous go to
their website cbdlion.com
read read the third party lab results if
there's some you don't know about cbd
you'll know it after you read the third
party lab results see what cbd cbn and
cby could do for you go to cbdline.com
right now
read
and order yourself some tincture or some
cream for your knee or some kinesiology
tape for your shoulder or a back ball to
put in the bathtub for your back cbd
lion has you covered press and co joey
or joint and get 20 off the product
delivered right to your house that's the
deal uncle joey's showing up with today
cbd lion code word joey or joint
let's get this [__] party
started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 27th of the month
halloween week i love this [__] week
i've always loved this week i mean
listen it's not like i'm gonna go
[__] trick-or-treating
or whatever i eat like a bag of m m's
that's it you know lately that's how i
fall asleep because at night when i go
upstairs i go i stop in the spare
bedroom and i get the cat
she's out cold in there laying down i
need my little service cat so i go in
there and get gray and when i'm going
together what i do is i turn the light
on but there's a ceiling fan
if you turn the ceiling fan on she don't
like it she's scared of that [__]
ceiling fan she just keeps looking at
the ceiling fan the whole time when you
turn it on
so i'll stop by the by the office and my
wife had all my wife's doing trunk or
treat you know where you get your cars
and you put them in the parking lot the
kids come from trunk to trunk
so they they're [__] hurting my
daughter upstairs [__] filling bags
up of candy so i swear to god like maybe
not last week maybe the week before for
like three nights in a row
i would go upstairs and get the cat and
i would look on the bed and there'd be a
bag of m m's those little little tiny
bags those little snack bags like eight
m m's in them i'd [__] open those
things up right as i'm going to bed and
i put them in my mouth as i'm walking to
piss before i go to bed and i lay in bed
for 10 minutes i get a little sugar buzz
but what comes up must go down
that's the best sleeping pill there is
[__] nine or ten m m's i was sleeping
like a [__] baby dog just
grabbing some m ms and hitting the
[__] crib and
ba boom
that's how you sleep stop no it's true
you get that little sugar buzz and next
thing you know i'm waking up at five in
the morning going [__] i passed out i
ate those nine [__] m ms
i'm [__] out of it jack great week so
far
shitty day yesterday [__] world
series last night
tremendous i love listen i love this
time of the year i love
the weather is nice i i tell you
when it comes to jersey new york the
east coast listen to me i don't know
boston gets a little colder
i got to be honest with you the best
months to be here april and may
and [__] september and october the
summer sucked this summer we got rain
every weekend we got rain during the
week [__] september first came and it
was beautiful it was 60 to 80 every
[__] day
sun shining hotter than [__] you could
look i walked around with a [__] tan
i just sit out there 10 15 minutes a
[__] day
uh it's been a gorgeous [__] month
the
leaves are starting to change you know
this time of the year is [__] great
there's only one thing that gets to me
around now once i see the halloween
commercials like once october
15th comes
i start getting a little sad man it's
weird because
i keep my composure pretty much i think
i i broke down on here one time in
february it was ralphie may i was taking
those pain pills and i was all [__] up
but it's weird i don't really get down
about things like i get down like i got
down a couple weeks ago when it was
ralphie's anniversary
on october 6th when i say get down i
mean
i just get quiet for a few hours you
know it's not like i'm crying or i get
[__] depressed or you know none of
that [__] i'm not gonna tell you it's
the end of the world none of that [__]
you know these people i'm having a rough
day now
this [__]
this makes me think
it just makes me think like this time of
the year
makes me think because uh november 8th
not this monday coming this monday
coming is november 1st
but the following monday is november 8th
and that's my mother's 42nd death
anniversary
42 [__] years
now i sit here sometimes and i say to
myself what the [__] happened
like how the [__] did i live 58 years
already
58 i'm 50 [__] eight
i was just 21 i was just 27. i was just
33 i was just 44.
i was 50 and then one day you're [__]
58. you don't that's
that's the
those are the denominations i remember
i'm not gonna lie to you guys i remember
when i'm 21 when i'm 25 i went to jail
when i'm 33 i got into comedy i remember
that
you know when i was 37 i was in seattle
[__] around when i was 40 i was now
you know i was in la when i was 37 what
am i talking about but
and then i was four i remember being 44
and going i got to quit doing coke i got
to get my life together and here we are
14 [__] years later but time [__]
flew i mean
you know when you're in high school time
is like [__] dead even the summers
are slow but once high school ends it
seems like it just moves
it just moves i just remember it being
august 28 to me going to [__]
pittsburgh
it's already october
[__] 27th i was just in pittsburgh
two [__] months ago those two months
just flew [__] by i still remember
going wow in three months the many
saints are coming out
it's out it's been out for a [__]
month it's just
time is flying but not to lose track of
what we're talking about here when it
comes to my mom like
everybody knows i experienced death at a
young age
so it's kind of crazy whenever somebody
loses somebody i'm their first [__]
email i'm their first message
whether beyond and i'm not talking about
friends of mine i'm talking about people
who follow the podcast
people who follow me on patreon people
follow me on twitter instagram i swear
to god
when they lose a family member
nine out of ten i'm the first guy they
send the message to
and it's a sad message you know i got a
couple on patreon this summer
from guys that lost their mom and they
were [__] miserable
and they always ask me the same question
they go joey how long
am i going to feel shitty for and i lied
to him
i lie to him i lie to you and i'm sorry
i do i have to lie to you because i
cannot tell you the truth
at that time
i lie to people when they email me i
tell them listen man
i'm sorry for your loss
i know how close you were with moms i
mean everybody's close with moms we have
disagreements from time to time we don't
agree with them
but it's your mom you know so i
understand where you're coming from
and to answer your question about how
long do you feel shitty for
[Music]
i go
just uh
you're gonna feel shitty for a while a
bit you know
that's a big [__] lie
and then i tell them the simplest answer
right now because it's what i did
grow up
to be the man your mother wanted you to
be
you ever been in the kitchen and your
mom just says stupid [__] to you like
i really want you to join the marines
and you're like oh boy
you know i really want you to be a
doctor and you're like [__] i really
want you to do this
my mom used to talk to me about that
[__] the way all moms do i don't know if
your mom talked to you about that stuff
but she would talk to me about uh
you know when you get older when you
when you get married i don't think you
should [__] drink my mom would say
little [__] things to me you know
and i would like say i'm [__] eight
who's thinking about getting married
who's talking about getting married here
what the [__] who brought that up you
know my mom would just say she would
just say
little things like that so what i tell
people usually is
listen man you want to make this easier
it's going to take a while
but to answer your question
grow up to be the man
your mother wanted you to be
and then they write me back that sounds
great thank you for getting back to me i
don't think they really understand what
i'm saying
nobody does nobody could under what do
you mean the man my mother wanted me to
me
if they say their father died
i also tell them that
grow up to be the woman or the man
your father wanted you to be
that's really [__] important right
there
that's really important
i when my mother died i'm gonna tell you
guys the evolution of it and some of
these are gonna be like what the [__]
joey
when i found my mother on the floor
november 8th that night at three in the
[__] morning i was tripping on acid
and i found her on the floor i didn't
know what to expect
even today it still feels like a [__]
dream it was all a dream
i used to read word up magazine
uh
you know i i thought it was a [__]
dream you know i
finding your mother on the floor it's
something that you never imagined
you know growing up or whatever even now
not really growing up because you don't
imagine those things
but now like i look at people and go man
that guy is getting old he's getting up
there
i don't know how much time he's got left
you know
and uh
and whatever you know you know with my
mother i never even looked at her and
went like
i couldn't even imagine my mother dying
i could not even process that through my
brain the test of that was in the eighth
grade i dated a girl i was gonna go down
there and fool around with a little bit
i mean we weren't having sex we were dry
humping sucking tits that type of [__]
i was gonna go down there and hang out
with him one afternoon like on [__]
uh columbus it was in february it's like
one of those washington birthdays
because this is in the old days for you
people who don't remember they
celebrated lincoln's birthday on the
12th and ken and uh george washington
birthday on the 19th so you got two
mondays off back to back in february now
they're [__] chintzy about it they
give us one [__] day for both [__]
dudes that sucks dick but
but uh i went down there on a monday we
had off and i was all hot and sticky
ready to [__] go
and i said uh what time is your dad get
home she goes about five like what time
is your mom get home she goes my mom is
dead hard on died listen to me i was in
the eighth grade you know in eighth
grade you're eternally [__] horny
like that's all you [__] think about
is [__] sucking but nobody's [__]
you nobody's sucking your dick you
you're not even in the [__] ballpark
and i'm saying but
i was hoping that you know i would have
sex i hope i think you know and i go
down there she tells me she's got no
mother
holy [__]
my dick just died i looked at this chick
and i was like
what do you mean you got no [__]
mother and she's like my mother died
when i was a little girl in the back of
my mind i'm like what could you have
done in your previous life
to lose your [__] mother that was
like [__]
unheard of to me that your mother died i
didn't think moms died i thought moms
died when you turned 50 or something
when you could handle it but for your
mom just i swear to god for your mom
just to die like that just
die i never even thought that was
possible
i never thought that was possible i
dumped that girl when i walked out of
that [__] apartment that february
12th that monday at two in the afternoon
i never [__] saw her again she kept
calling me it took me about a week to
say listen i can't see you no more
because i'm going away for basketball
camp and i'll be training for freshman
summer ball and all this [__] and she's
like what are you talking about you live
three miles away and i'm like yeah but
i'm just gonna be i did not want she
called me crying she was upset i did not
give a [__] i was not hanging around
with somebody who didn't have a mom that
is not gonna happen in my realm so what
happens two years later i lose my
[__] mind
so the first person that came to mind
when i saw my mom on the floor
with that purple [__] arm
was colleen that was her name colleen
i'll never forget it in fact i've even
you know how many times i've gone on
facebook found her
and i want to send her a message to
apologize for my behavior in 1978 and i
can't i can't i was i was i was a
[__] jerk off door you know at least
i
and i wasn't meant or anything i just
stopped talking to her i just couldn't
even deal with a person that didn't have
a mother i was like this is terrible you
know is like satan's cousin or some [__]
she don't have a [__] mother i can't
deal with her
so i thought i even go on facebook now
she lives in ramsey new jersey or
something like that
i found that she's still a [__]
knockout but i mean for the five years
for like 10 years i've been trying to
apologize to her and i just can't
so when i found my mom i mean i was numb
me when somebody dies
you're in shock your body goes into
shock you don't know it you don't feel
it
you don't feel it coming over you but
your body's in [__] shock your
mental's in shock i remember the next
day i went to [__] school
in fact that's what really made me think
about my mom because it was
i took mercy last monday to the baking
class
and as i was going in they said remember
the state [__] uh whatever the
teachers convention
no school november 5th 4th and 5th and
i'm like [__] and that was the week my
mother died my mother's anniversary is
really the eighth
but she really
she died
on a tuesday night and that that's the
week that you have school
on monday and wednesday but you're off
tuesday thursday and friday so when i
found my mom on tuesday night i dog i
went to school
i didn't know what to do i couldn't sit
along with my [__] thoughts
in a house that i was [__] scared of
as it was a haunted [__] house so i
just got up and went to [__] school i
didn't know what to do
and then one of the teachers saw him and
he goes didn't your mom die last night
i'm like yeah
he goes what the [__] are you doing here
i go what are my options what are you
gonna do sit at home and wait and they
go no we gotta take you home you can't
be it so they drove me the [__] home and
i went home and i had to deal with it
but what really bothered me about
my mother's death was after i buried him
i'm ashamed to tell you guys this
but
it'll yeah i'll clear it up
for 45 days i didn't feel nothing we
buried my mom like on the 12th or the
13th
my aunt zarida the lady i did the comedy
central this is not happening about
stayed with me till thanksgiving day
until i moved in with the benders and i
got to be honest with you guys
i didn't feel anything
i didn't feel numb as a matter of fact
like by mid-december
i was questioning myself like
did i not love this woman
what the [__] is the matter with me man
i'm not struggling
i was out partying at night i was having
a good [__] time
but that album by pink floyd came out
the wall
and the wall had a song mother on it
that album came out november 28 1979
my mom died november 8 1979 so that
album was the most popular [__] album
of all time
so the whole month of december that
album was anywhere you went
that album was on and there's a song in
that album called mother mother do you
think she'll drop the bomb all that [__]
and i would go to these places and i
would be in there and this song would
come on and i would [__] shun it like
i would just
shut it down in my my mind and in my
ears i would just try to shut it down as
much as i could
and this went on for a few weeks every
time that song came on and i could see
even my friends whenever that whenever
we were playing that song
in the shed my friends were always like
you know
try to lower it or let's put on a
different arm and i would go no no leave
the wall on don't don't [__] change
because of me you know
but one night it was like [__]
a little after
christmas a couple nights after
christmas
and i went to one of those [__]
parties and i was sitting there with my
friends having a great [__] time and
that song came on
and i was high and it just took me
somewhere
i don't know it's just
my emotion my whole state of mind
changed like a sadness just came over my
[__] body it was rough
people told me that once when somebody
dies the hardest is the first holiday
you know thanksgiving was a little rough
but again that's why i was like [__] i'm
not really going through this i thought
i would be breaking down and crying all
the time that wasn't the case at all
december came
as the holidays approached i got a
little sad but again i wasn't sad enough
to
stay in or anything like that so
i just played the [__] hand but that
night after christmas like two or three
nights after christmas
whoo whenever i think of that man
i [__] was at a party we were all
having a good time talking to chicks you
know the whole [__] deal and all of a
sudden that album came on and
mother came on and i was like [__] i'm
getting anxiety something wasn't right i
didn't feel right
and i went outside i stood by a car for
a little while
and all of a sudden i started feeling
dizzy it wasn't the alcohol
it wasn't the weed it wasn't the acid it
wasn't none of that [__] i know you're
like joey you were probably on two it's
acid and drinking no no no what i'll
tell you when
something like that just something it
was like a uh
my whole body was sad
and i went outside and it was december
28th 27th guys it's [__] freezing out
and i couldn't go back into that party
this thing had taken over me
and out of nowhere i started
i don't know where i just started
barfing barf and barfing
it was like my stomach had had it
everything that had it
and all i could think about was my
mother in that cemetery freezing because
it was so [__] colder that's all i
could think about i go she's out there
with a [__] dress on and a casket
freezing her [__]
and in my [__] acidy mind i'm like
i'm going to go down there and get her
out of that [__] casket
that was horrible
i [__] went down
you know there was a a fence you know
outside the cemetery and i knew the post
that lined up
with her grave you know with her
gravestone i already knew the post
because when i would walk to school
i would stop and just look at the grave
for a few minutes just to make sure she
was dead at this point 45 days later my
mind was telling me she wasn't dead it
was [__] horrible
so i'll never forget that i [__]
jumped the fence
and i had gloves on and i go you know
what i don't have a [__] shovel i
have nothing i found like a [__] twig
and i started digging
up the [__] body like not digging it
up i was like scraping the dirt the
ground was frozen i wasn't gonna get
nowhere
after about 20 30 [__] minutes i
started scraping that [__] ground
scraping and scraping
and i'm like you know what this is
[__] crazy
and there was something else going on
that i need to tell you this is how
[__] crazy the mind is
had her wake
everybody kept putting little bundles of
cocaine in her casket
i stopped counting like a 20. there must
have been an ounce of coke and little
aluminum foils in that casket
i was also going to break into the
casket and try to steal the [__] coke
too that's don't don't get me wrong here
don't think that i'm a [__] angel oh
joey's going to dig up his mother
because he missed her now there was
cocaine in that casket that's what else
i was [__] thinking about you know
i'm a dirty bastard
but the beautiful thing was that
while i was digging the [__]
well i was trying to dig the grave i
caught myself
and i was like what the [__] is going on
here
and i remember that like it was
yesterday me just like straightening out
and going god
just [__] take me you know i don't
think i could do this anymore
and i laid there for a couple minutes it
was [__] freezing out
and i go you know what she's not even in
this [__] grave that's how demented i
was
i was like she's home and i got out of
the [__] cemetery and i walked
straight to my [__] given that
terrace
and i'll never forget making that left
turn on the corner and looking at my
house and the lights were all turned off
i was like [__]
so i walked up to the house i had the
keys to the house
but i was too scared to open the door
so i just rang the doorbell
i must have rang the doorbell 50 [__]
times
and i kept telling the ma open up the
door she was [__] dead i saw her at
the funeral parlor i saw her in a
[__] casket i saw them close the
casket i saw them do the math the mask
master math
i saw them do the mass
and i saw them put her on the [__]
ground i actually personally picked up a
shovel and threw dirt on her and threw a
rose on top
and my mind still couldn't believe
that she was [__] dead that's
insane to me when i think of that
it just makes me [__] sad as [__]
you know the last year
i struggled a lot with my mental health
with the withdrawals i was just [__]
going nuts and
i thought about like when was the last
time i struggled like this
and it was then i couldn't get it
together you know the reason why i write
a journal for my daughter
and i give them to my wife i tell my
wife i go listen i'm going to probably
have 10 journal i don't know when i'm
going to die i mean that's that's a
thousand dollar question i don't know
when the [__] i'm going to die but
i don't know how many journals i'm gonna
have for her but as soon as i die and as
soon as you bury me you have to give her
these journals
because i don't want her to lose it the
way i lost it
you know as children we all have ant
questions
you know when you lose a parent we we
forgot to ask them certain questions you
know i was 16 when my mother died
when i was a kid i asked questions but
once i turned
once i became a teenager i never asked
any [__] questions what do i give a
[__] i'm trying to get my dick sucked
i'm trying to [__] figure out how to
get my dick sucked i don't give a [__]
about what my grandmother was born or
when my
my father went to school and all that
[__] i didn't give a [__] about that
but that was part of my torment
that's what drove me to snore coke
that's what drove me to far i mean
when i got back to new jersey last year
i
you know i was scared of covered we all
were you know were cautious or coveted
but i also had a little fear in my heart
of coming back here for all the things i
had done
you know i really let my friends down
i let myself down i let a lot of people
down i did some [__] bad [__] before
i left here in 83 85 and
when i got back here i remembered a lot
of those things like it came up to my
mind
and it affected me a little bit it
affected who i talked to i just wanted
to make sure that there was no bad blood
i didn't want any beefs on anybody you
know i was coming back here for 20 years
just a weekend or two weekends a year i
knew it was going to be different when i
moved back here
so
i thought about all the bad things i had
done and i couldn't believe that that
was me and i'm going to tell you
something i would love to be able to
blame it on cocaine you know everybody
blames [__] on cocaine and there's a lot
of things i blame on cocaine because now
i realize that it was the cocaine that
made me do it i didn't have those things
in my heart it wasn't in my heart to
kidnap somebody it wasn't that's never
been in my heart to throw somebody in
the trunk of a car and it's never been
in my heart to steal something i always
hated stealing something don't get me
wrong i love shoplifting lighters from
time to time from 7-eleven you know what
i'm saying everybody likes to steal a
good lighter but my
i was never a [__] thief guys
i never dreamed of robbing a jewelry
store or robbing the amount of houses
or robbing the businesses and the drug
dealers i did i'm very ashamed of what i
did but i got to be honest with you i
was out of my head at the time
i was a 17 year old kid who had just
lost his [__] mother
i didn't know that i was coming or going
you guys know me for years you guys know
i'm not a big guy for making [__]
excuses
but this is an excuse i have to make
because it's the truth
and i just realized that recently i
realized that maybe six months ago when
i was journaling that
the things i had done weren't from the
heart of joey diaz
it was
from the heart of the cocaine the
cocaine just had me [__] crazy i
didn't know that
i would never blame anything on cocaine
you guys know that when i kidnapped ken
bella the attorney even said to me hey
you went to the dentist this morning
they put you on the nitrous oxide i can
maybe get you a [__] a different case
maybe get the charges dropped you didn't
know what you were doing and i said no
i knew what i was doing
i knew what i was doing it was the
torment of the coke that made me rob
that guy
don't ever get it wrong yeah
you know i got my teeth fixed that
morning and the whole thing
but
that's [__] it was me who did it and
it's the same thing when i talk about
these things that i did listen guys
when i was a young kid i was confused
i had lost
my hero
i was trying to figure out the world
without my [__] hero and i did some
things that were [__] uh
you know
if i would have been a woman i would
have been promiscuous
you know i didn't think any i had no
value in my life i had i had nothing i
had [__] nothing i had nothing to
rest back on i had done anything
i hadn't done anything nothing i was
just a [__] kid
so i didn't know one thing or another
now i know if my mother was to die today
and i went out and started robbing
houses at 58 years old we got a [__]
problem
you know first of all i don't even think
i could rob a [__] house i'm too fat
to be a burglar i don't think i could
fit in the [__] window now i'll pick
my try i remember when i tried to break
into my own house i had a hard time i
climbed in the window and i landed my
stomach landed on the windowsill and i
got stuck there for like [__] eight
minutes and all i could do is feel this
[__] out coming out of my [__] and i
had a [__] in the backyard and the
landlord thought it was a [__] bear i
can't break in the houses no more my
[__] burglary days are over it's got
to be a quick one i kick the door in
take the [__] box of cookies and get
the [__] out i can't i don't have time
to be looking around i don't have cardio
or endurance when you [__] rob [__]
your heart beats up a storm and you hear
like a little [__] whistle while
you're robbing you like a little beep
because you're nervous you your
adrenaline is up your [__] heart is
bumping
i would have a heart attack now my fat
little heart couldn't [__] handle
that but to get back to the [__]
story i i would have lost my mind
and like i said if i was a woman i would
have probably became promiscuous
i would have done [__] like that because
you do things to yourself i would have
probably become a slicer
years later i mean the thievery
once the thievery disappeared
the cocaine took over it wasn't even the
pain of my mother anymore it was the
[__] cocaine
and i [__] was picking my face with a
tweezer and getting holes in my face
which is uh another [__]
gesture for [__]
slicing it's it's slicing but in a
different [__] way i wouldn't look at
myself in the mirror when i was coked up
all these things were from coke that's a
complete different [__] story when i
kidnapped bella that was from coke but
all those things i did early on
before 1985 like when i [__] beat my
godfather
do you have any idea how much i love my
i think about my godfather every time
i see charles bronson every time i see
steve mcqueen
every time i see one of these old movies
that i saw as a child i think about my
[__] godfather and how good he was to
me
what the [__] possessed me
to beat him you know not beat him in a
fight i didn't beat him like that i beat
him out of money for cocaine you know
what possessed me to do something like
this
you know i hunt him down
you know i don't know if he's dead i
know he was alive last thing i heard he
was down in the florida keys
when i hired the investigator for my
daughter i had him [__] look for him
he couldn't my daughter he could find
this guy he could not [__] find he
could not find a death certificate for
him so we're trying to figure out what
yeah i don't know what happened to my
god yeah still i don't know where my god
i mean he's 80 something years old you
know i'm saying he's not mad at me no
more but i would love to
i would love to get the chance to
apologize for what i did to him
you know my uncle i i [__] with him up
too thank god we have a great
relationship today i was mad enough to
[__]
go down there shake his hand apologize
to him i have no
problems with apologizing right now what
i'm trying to get to the root of the
matter is
why i did it
and that's why i did it my mother's
death
took me down hard man it just wasn't a
death i see
people
listen there's always a reaction to
death
you're always going to react a certain
way you're going to notice that you're
drinking a lot more
maybe you're doing more drugs maybe
you're doing more
anxiety medication there's something
but there's always always a reaction to
a death
sometimes it's minimal sometimes people
i have a friend who lost his daughter
lost his [__] daughter in a car
accident
i talked to him monthly we've been
friends for
[__] since i started comedy maybe
[Music]
92 you know and he lost her daughter
i call him a lot i talked to him a lot
didn't affect him at all he's got
another child and
he moved on from me you know i was
thinking about sylvester stallone the
other day he's re-releasing rocky iv
and i was thinking how he lost his son
maybe eight years ago seven years ago
six years ago
and he's doing great he didn't end up
robbing anybody or [__] jumping out
windows or lighting anybody on fire you
know what i'm saying i mean
the way i reacted to my mom's debt is
the way a child would react to something
like that i didn't [__] know any
better
but
today
in 2021
42 years after her death november 8th
this weekend is halloween weekend
and
what happened basically was this
halloween 1979
i went to a party
i told my mother
it was an adult party it was all the
kids party i told my mother a few days
before that i'm going to this party blah
blah blah blah she's like listen i don't
care if you go to the party
just remember the [__] rule
let me know what time you're gonna come
home call blah blah blah blah blah you
know you got a call every so what it
meant was
as i was leaving the house if i looked
at him i go i'll be home early she would
say what time i would say
let's say midnight so during the week i
would tell him my curfew was 12
and i would be home at 10 45 11. i just
would say 12. but on the weekend i would
say 12. and if i wasn't home at 12 i had
to call her i had to stop what i was
doing call her
and say listen i'm not going to be home
and then she would say what time are you
going to be home
2.
i would just throw out that too
and she would go fine i'll see you too
if you're not gonna be home at two make
sure you call me that was the rule in
the house
and i stuck to it i stuck to it because
i didn't want any problems i didn't want
to get punished i had a great life i was
allowed to stay out my friends can only
be out till [__] 10 o'clock i could
stay after two there was only two kids
in the neighborhood that could stay out
till two me and this other [__] guy
that's it brett ernst has a great joke
about that he grew up in jersey and
growing up in jersey there's always one
kid that's always out
you go out at three in the morning he's
always out what are you doing that was
me growing up i was always [__] out i
didn't want to go home early in case i
missed something
you don't want to be joe jerk off after
you leave some chick shows up and sucks
everybody's dick but you were at home
watching betty hill like a [__] that
you are you know what i'm saying so you
never want to go home when you're having
fun when you're in this neighborhood so
i uh
i just didn't
i didn't have
a [__] curfew
so the night of the halloween party it
wasn't really on the 31st it was like on
the weekend
[Music]
i stayed out til five in the morning i
called
but the last time i had called she
sounded tired so i said i'm not gonna
call anymore i've already called
eight times in the [__] night and
when i got home that night we got into a
[__] argument she's like where the
[__] have you been you're supposed to
call and i was just sick of his [__] you
know i was 16. in my mind i was a man so
i gave her some [__] [__] answer
and she smacked me
smacked me like once or twice i went to
my room
i could tell that she had a lot in her
i don't mind my mom at that time she was
broke she lost her business
she was struggling i on the other hand i
was making money i was selling drugs i
hit the number i was helping her out
with dope
and she came up the next morning and she
woke me up and apologized
and she said something to me that stayed
with me the whole [__] time
and it
i heard it
right after i thought about colleen's
mother
my mother said listen i really don't
give a [__] what you do i just you know
what that's important to me
is that you grow up to be a man
and now she has said this to me a couple
times over the year over the years but
but this time it sounded
um
this time it sounded
real and it sounded different
like after it was all over and when i
was out that day i thought about it i
can't believe my mother told me to grow
up to be a [__] man
and by a man she doesn't mean a guy
that's
getting his dick sucked and [__] on
she just
to understand my mother was a big woman
lady like she wasn't a feminist or
whatever these [__] crazy women are
today
she just backed women you know like my
mother
raised me to be [__] tight with women
so she would mention to me little things
that i had to do
as you know she would just say to me
when you get older and you're married
you gotta do this for your wife you
gotta do i would look at like who the
[__] is getting married
you know like i would always say those
things to her but she was preparing me
she was telling me little things
and after she died like that day when i
that night when i found her on the floor
and i looked at her
and i'm like yeah [__] i can't believe i
was not friends with colleen anymore
because she didn't have a mother now i'm
the same person i also said [__]
she wanted me to grow up to be a man
now i understand what it is and after
the [__] ambulance took her that
night i sat on my steps
for maybe an hour and a half thinking of
those words
and part of the reason i was cutting
myself all those years
part of the reason i was doing the drugs
part of the reason i wasn't happy
was because i wasn't a man
november
15th
that's the day i stopped snorting
cocaine
and that was the day i was officially on
my way
to becoming a man
and after i got my head clear like after
60 days and stuff
i didn't go to aaa i didn't use aaa to
stay clean or na to stay clean they
would have been a great option i didn't
use them not because i didn't want to
because i used my mother's words as my
therapy
all those things she had said to me over
the years
you know whether it was grow up to be a
man you know
when you take the garbage out for your
wife no woman wants to come home and see
a husband sitting on a couch watching tv
my my wife my my wife my mom would just
say little things to me
like little things like listen your wife
doesn't want you to clean the house but
she appreciates if you clean your toilet
you know my mother taught me to clean
the bathroom so i would clean the
toilets and today
from time to time i clean the toilets i
take the garbage out from my wife i
support my wife i'm a father to my
daughter you know when i make a mistake
i cop up to it hey i made a mistake what
do you want from me
these are all the traits of a man
this is what a man is supposed to do
the bigger the man the bigger the
mistake
you know
apologize [__]
stick to your word you know when you
write your goals stick to your [__]
goals you know i was telling somebody
that i've been taping for the last six
months
nobody's watching me i'm not part of a
program i'm not involved with a rehab or
anything like that i can do whatever the
[__] i want i have not missed it one
time
you know why because i finally became a
man and i became a man [__] late guys
i became a man at the age of 49 at the
age of 50
was when everything came to my mind for
me that i was prepared to be a man
i was not a man before that i was just a
[__] big kid and i'm a big kid now i
laugh at farts and i scratch my nuts and
sniff my fingers
and all that dumb [__] but
in the big picture i'm a man
and that's what i'm very thankful for
like for me to bust through this [__]
thing i was going through
you know
even like the other day i was talking on
the podcast about better help with
therapy
all this has helped me but my therapy
was made easier because i knew
that i had accomplished my mom's dreams
for me
sometimes we achieve our goals and i
achieved my goals i hit the spot i i did
more than what i anticipated i was gonna
[__] do and that's okay
but there was one other thing i had to
do until for me to be happy
and that was
become a man
under my mom's standards
were for being a man
and i reached it and for that today
i'm proud so i want to dedicate today's
uncle joey's joint
to dinorah valdez my mother
because for the first time in my life i
can look at the pictures
and be happy i'm going to tell you
something else
but i don't care if you people think i'm
crazy
i don't care if you people think i'm out
of my [__] mind
the last year
every night
i don't do it every night i do it maybe
four or five nights a week i turn the tv
off
before i go upstairs
i got a picture of my mother in the
basement i got a picture of my father
i sit on my chair and i just have a
conversation with them
as crazy as it sounds
i thank her
for giving me those words for me to
become a man and i thank my father i
tell him to look after my child
i tell him to look after my wife i tell
him to look after me and i and i
tell him i love him i do that four or
five nights a week to myself sometimes
out loud sometimes to myself i like to
do it out loud so i hear the words
so it makes me feel better it brings me
comfort
so today's podcast is dedicated to
dinora valdez
she's going to be dead
42 [__] years
and i still miss her like she died
[__] yesterday i still love her as
much as i do
so when you reach out to me with a
message
about somebody in your family died your
mom or your dad
i'm gonna lie to you
but i want you to understand that
it never goes away the pain never goes
away
the
thinking about them never goes away
missing their food never goes away
missing their smell the way their hair
smells or it never goes away and guess
what
that's good because they're not dead
do you follow me
dead dead
when you don't stop thinking about them
but every time you think about them and
go mom thank you for today
dad thank you for today you know all
those things
you're keeping them alive they're not
dead
they're still alive in your heart
so
i don't know what you do to
make yourself feel better when you think
about a grandmother or grandfather i
know there was a lot of loss
with the pandemic the last two years i
know a lot of people suffered
so i hope these words
help you these words come for you
i haven't done one of these podcasts in
a while i'm sorry i didn't have a guest
today but i wanted to do this podcast
with my mom i had been thinking about it
for a week and i was starting to go into
it on monday's podcast and i was like no
i'm not ready yet and today i was ready
so we'll have a guest uh next wednesday
for november i'll uh
light a candle for her on november 8th
two mondays
from yesterday
and that's it guys the pain never goes
away
or you could do is be a better person
to make them happy so you could be happy
about the transition
i don't feel bad about my mother no more
like there was a time i felt shitty
because i wasn't living the life she
wanted me to live
today
october 27
even though it took me 42 years
today i'm living the life she wanted me
to live
and for that
i'm [__] happy as [__]
and that's today's uncle joey's joint i
hope you [__] enjoyed it
i hope you [__] got something
out of it
i know a lot of years like i said lost
somebody i hope this podcast helps you
today
and that's it i just want you to know
i'm in your [__] corner
you got this
and if you didn't get one of those
laughing gas blunts yet you're [__]
slipping [__] because that'll
help you get through the pain too i
don't know if i was telling mike for you
guys that don't know that laughing glass
blunt has an eighth of weed in it
it's got an eighth of [__] weed in it
i want you guys to know you [__] with
that blunt you're gonna [__] end up
on the
losing side of that [__] blunt i'm
just letting you know right now so you
know laughing gas blunt is available at
the ice cream shop it is [__]
tremendous that i that weed won another
award last week
in san diego it had won that cup
when it first came out a year ago
that weed is on [__] fire so if
you're not [__] around with laughing
gas
now i'm gonna bring it here with
backwoods blunt you're gonna pay for it
but remember it's a hell of a [__]
blunt
and it's got three and a half grams in
there
it's not your [__] ordinary blunt and
it's got treated thc paper to push you
over the top so if you didn't want to
jump off that building when you smoke
this you will jump off that
[__] building
i hope this podcast helps you out
thank you for listening to the joint
thank you for watching the joint i love
you [__] with all my heart i'll
see you [__] next monday november
[__] first all
souls day
stay black have a great weekend
and i'll see you [__] monday
morning
tip top magoo november 1st
stay black and now
for a word for my [__] sponsor
jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you guys
for listening to the dedication to my
mom today i had a good time doing this
podcast
i wanted to get off my chest but before
we leave
a word from our sponsors the podcast is
brought to you by today wednesday the
27th cbd lion for all your cbd needs
cbd lion is there for you do me a favor
go to cbdline.com read the third party
lab results
read about all their products and get
the help that you need today
whether it's aches pains
anxiety you can't sleep cbd line will
have something to help you again go to
cbdlion.com
press and code joey or join
and get 20 off
cbd lion delivered to your house the
joint is also brought to you by
draftkings.com the official sports
betting partner of the ufc the official
sports betting partner of the nba and
the official sports betting partner of
the nfl this saturday night live from
abu dhabi it's ufc 267 blankowicz
against glover texera listen draftkings
is there what we're gonna do is this
if you bet five dollars on any fighter
if your guy wins
you get 203 bets 203 bets will the champ
hang on to his belt or will the veteran
from brazil snatch it from him either
way if you bet five bucks you could win
200 and free bets if your fighter wins
listen to me i love draftkings why
because you can't bet over your head
everything is controlled
okay plus they got all the sports you
need from soccer to rugby to [__]
table tennis in china to [__] social
media so once you join draftkings you
got uncle joey on social media [__]
around with you it's fun whether you use
the casino whether you bet on basketball
or the ufc this is the time of the year
you got the world series you got ufc
next week 268 live from madison square
garden why are we having this
conversation draftkings is safe secure
reliable and you can withdraw your cash
whenever the [__] you want download the
draftking sportsbook app today right now
use promo code joey you throw down files
on any ufc 267 main event and you win
and free bets if your fighter comes
through that's code joey this saturday
night at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc you got to be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customers
only minimum hour deposit that's all i'm
asking you for and a one dollar wage is
required
one per customer that's the only problem
you can only do it one time and
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gambling palm you got to call 1-800
gamble you got to take care that
or 1-800 with it
if you're in indiana but if you don't
have any problems it's time to download
the daily fantasy app from draftkings or
the sports betting app from draftkings
and it's time to make some [__]
money
i love draftkings and so
the [__] will you the joint is also
brought to you by the best underwear of
all time me on these made with modal the
softest
[__] thing on this planet
they're comfortable they're soft and
i'll tell you what's good about
thanksgiving these puppies can [__]
stretch because if you're eating [__]
me undies if you're eating thanksgiving
at my house you're gonna need me on
these we got pasta we got meatballs we
got everything you could eat seconds you
could eat thirds and you don't have to
worry about your [__] band and the me
undies ain't like the regular underwear
where if a fat guy puts them on and then
you put them on they're [__] the same
size ah
me undies are [__] tremendous they're
perfect this thanksgiving give your
gratitude some attitude you might not
get along with your [__] crazy family
but if you give your cranky old [__]
grandpa some brand new undies he might
[__] flip his wig he's been wearing
those cotton [__]
pieces of [__] with yellow stains since
he was born since 1908 take a chance
grandpa columbus did [__] me on
these is the perfect partner to get you
through the holidays you throw on your
[__] onesie forget about it it'll hug
your butt with softness perfect for
watching the game
taking a post in a nap while you scratch
your balls the best part is me undies is
for everybody available in sizes from
extra small to 4 xl me undies has a
little something for everybody at the
[__] table now me undies is a
great offer for you
for the joint family and you know i love
me on these guys
they're great and you know what i
stopped wearing underwear because i hate
wearing underwear with jeans
because the [__] that just makes me
feel creepy with me on these i don't
have that problem because they're the
best underwear made
comfortable they fit right they hug your
nut sack you don't sweat because the
material keeps it ventilates your nut
sack oh my god you manscape your nuts
and then you put me on these on ba-boom
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason you can return your order
for a full refund within 45 days
that's the me undies guarantee
what i'm going to do is i'm going to get
you 15 off your first order
free shipping and 100 satisfaction
guarantee do me a favor go to
meundies.com
joey meundies.com
joey that's meundies.com
joey the best underwear in the business
comfort and it just hugs you nuts snug
sack magnifique i want to thank me
undies i want to thank honett i want to
thank cbd lion
i want to thank draftkings
and who else do i have to thank you i
don't even know oh better help i want to
thank all you guys for sponsoring the
show this week they're five tremendous
[__] sponsors i love these companies
and i love you [__] too have a
great weekend
and i'll see you [__] monday
morning
tip top
[__] magoo i love you guys stay
black
[Music]
hmm
you